hey there final fantasy 7 remake finally
got its sleek ps5 upgrade and we're
comparing the ps4 pro to the ps5
but we're also trying out both the high
frame rate performance mode and the
beautiful graphics mode the ps5 version
offers
so you'll see a couple different
comparisons here if you enjoy final
fantasy 7 remake content let us know by
liking this video
it helps a ton alright here we go
watch out for live wires they're
everywhere
ugh the air in here reeks can't wait to
get out in the open
man what is that i've never smelled
anything so foul
oh it's me gotta do something about that
and soon
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
get down here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'd say you're not even reading the same
we're done book come on nobody do
something this crazy just for money
they may not think you're a true
believer but you know what i think not
interested
what
which
you better be worth the money merc every
last gill
[Music]
[Music]
was never in doubt
see you later up
that's it
here we go
maybe you're not okay
ah he lives finally awake are we
you're erin it's eric
and you are cloud
nice to meet you again again huh
what you don't remember what about
the flowers oh the flower girl
and this is an old church in the sector
five slums
you came crashing through the roof
without so much as a lookout below
fell right into my flower bed lucky for
you
like really sorry i didn't mean to don't
worry about it
they're a lot tougher than they look
this place
it has a kind of power
before i forget you dropped this when
you landed
thanks i've got one too
[Music]
you and everybody and their mother not
like mine
no it's special mine's not good for
anything at all
[Music]
bet you just don't know how to use it
could be though
i really don't mind just having it is
enough
was a gift from my mother
pretty crazy huh us meeting again like
this
you should stay a while
[Music]
you